hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a little clip from
my interview with dr rupe ortla the
doctor's kitchen now rupees had an
incredible career he started off working
as a doctor as a hospital doctor then
became a general practitioner and now he
educates people about how healthy eating
and healthy living can actually be a
really powerful form of medicine and
rupee has had so many battles with
imposter syndrome over the years when he
was first working as a doctor starting
to put himself out there online and so
in this little clip we're talking about
the idea of imposter syndrome how all of
us have it when it comes to putting
ourselves out there in any kind of
capacity and how we can overcome it so i
hope you enjoyed this clip you know this
is it was like a real cringe-worthy
moment for me
uh back then i was so scared about what
the reaction was gonna be um so i
actually uh clicked play and then i
jumped on a plane to japan and then i
got all these messages from people and
like that's amazing that's so cool and
like why are we scared i was just scared
at the time dude like you know
a gp talking about food as medicine
back then
when the wellness industry wasn't as
established as in as now like seven
years later it's it it would have been
seen i at least i thought it would have
been interpreted as a bit cavalier oh
yeah well like you want a qualified
nutritionist therefore how do you talk
about food kind of like that kind of
vibe but also like just generally like
uh getting in front of a camera and
being a doctor on youtube and instagram
and being that kind of person
sometimes it does feel like that yeah i
don't know if this was your experience
when you first got on because i i
remember hearing that
i think you did like 80 odd videos
before the the one that really kicked
everything off but
yeah
yeah i i always i i was never really
into social media at the time i wasn't
like you know someone who followed joe
wicks and all these other people i found
out about them after i joined myself i
hadn't really done much research in that
perspective i just knew what i wanted to
talk about so it came came from a place
of like just genuinely wanting to put
out good content out there were you
worried about what your doctor friends
would think absolutely that you're
peddling that oh i'm the doctor and
you're like oh i'm just a recently
qualified gp and like what the hell do i
know about anything absolutely
absolutely that was definitely and it's
still to this day if i'm being honest
there is a shred of that whenever i talk
about what i do and you know just by
completing a master's in nutritional
medicine doing all this analysis having
researchers on my team and all that kind
of stuff like i still get all that kind
of i still get that like little voice in
my head saying you don't really know
what you're talking about because i
guess the maybe you've experienced this
as well by doing so much research in
your various domains
the more you learn the more you realize
how little you know
and that you know for someone who
doesn't really want to be you know
misleading people or anything
the the the scary thing is like you know
what if people find out how much i how
little i know like always that in the
back of my mind i'm not a researcher
that spends like day in day out in a lab
reading papers all day long like i've
got a whole bunch of other things to do
um and you'll never have i'll never have
i have to
i've got you know better at um
working through this myself
i'm never gonna know enough to
completely get rid of my imposter
syndrome i just have to sit
well with how i am right now and do the
things that i know are helping people as
much as possible and just just be happy
with that
because otherwise it's you know
you just stop making content yeah
yeah this is the thing i hear from like
once once my channel started to go well
while i was still working um people
would be like oh you know like i had a
friend who was an obstetrics registrar
and you know he and his his wife had
recently gone through the whole process
and he was like you know there's a lot
of misinformation out there you know
it would be cool to do a book as an
obstetrics registrar about what it was
like being sort of going through the
process of the patient educating young
mothers about young mothers to be about
what the process is going to be like
he was like oh but i can't do it now i
need to i need to wait until i'm a
consultant because then i'll be
qualified i hear that i was like when
you're a consultant are you really gonna
are you really gonna think that or are
you gonna think oh i'm a new consultant
i need to wait until i've got a diploma
in reproductive medicine and i've been
uh bringing professor for 20 years
before i think that yeah and even in
that position you're probably going to
think i'm not the world's most qualified
person to talk about this therefore i
can't talk about it yeah and i think in
medicine there is a lot of credentialism
credentialization that goes on where
it's like we feel this internally we
feel our friends are going to judge us
for it maybe some of them do judge us
for it be like how dare you talk about
nutrition without a phd in nutritional
medicine masters anyone get a master's
through that it's just a one-year thing
phd is where it's really yeah like we
have this thing where we need another
badge another another certificate to be
allowed to do a thing absolutely and i
just try and try my best to be like look
you don't need any qualifications you're
being a guard you're not being a guru
yeah it's all good yeah absolutely
like what you've just described there
has happened to so many of my colleagues
who haven't got to that consultancy
status and then when they get to that
consultancy i've spoken to so many
different consultants who some of whom
have have actually been on the podcast
and asked for you know the you know oh i
i i didn't really i don't i didn't think
i said this right or i feel like i'm too
young a consultant to say these things
so i'd rather not do it like that's fine
that's you know i'm not gonna push
anything
but
it's a story i hear very often and it's
not just with the medicine so i'm
actually gonna call someone out here one
of my good friends um a guy called jay
who is a serial entrepreneur he's raised
millions of pounds
he has a number of different tech
companies under his belt
and he really wants to put out content
about conscious entrepreneurship right
he's super qualified to talk about it
he's been in the game for well over a
decade
and he just can't get over the edge he
just can't start with his first piece of
content to start the wheels in motion
because there's something holding him
back i'm not qualified enough i've only
been in the game for a couple of years i
haven't raised as much money as this
person so i think that sort of
credentialism
credentials i'm saying that wrong but um
the word that we just made up um
that i think holds a lot of people back
beyond medicine as well you know i
remember when i was first starting my
youtuber course which you know we
started uh sort of october 2020
and you know it has now become by far
the the that has been a a ridiculously
profitable decision but i remember
having a zoom call with two internet
friends of mine who also run courses and
saying to them
you know i don't really feel like i can
do a course teaching people how to be
youtubers like i've only got 1.2 million
subscribers and they were just like
oh yeah are you hearing yourself right
now i was like i mean i've only got 140
million subscribers like why why would
anyone sign up to youtube course for me
like what the hell do i know like to
talk to the guys got 20 million
subscribers
and they were like you have no idea what
you just said yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly
it happens everywhere that happens to
the best of us i think you know we
downplay our own
uh achievements um and it's like if you
don't
if you don't take a moment to actually
reflect on what you've achieved
then
you'll never really be happy always
chasing that next thing i actually wrote
in the acknowledgments of my third book
i wrote something that might be
perceived as narcissistic but it's
really trying to kick myself into
the gear of like taking pause looking
back at what i've achieved up to this
point even though in the day-to-day i
don't really think it's a big thing or
whatever i walk around like oh i'm a
sunday time's best
like i i wrote like take a moment to
enjoy this this present uh
peace just take uh i can't remember
exactly what i said but it was along the
lines of you're doing a good thing keep
going and believe in yourself and that's
it and i think
i have to remind myself of that every
day i actually have an affirmation that
i i read every single day to that effect
because it's very easily lost in this
world where we can constantly comparing
ourselves to someone who has more
followers or you know more achievements
or whatever the accolades that we
compare ourselves by and it's become
more prevalent i guess in this social
media driven world hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day